شكرا جزيلا لك يا صهيب نكمل نحن حيث ارقام
مقلقه عن التعليم في اوكرانيا في ظل الحرب
الحاليه او ولدتها منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله ينصف في اليوم العالمي للتعليم
اذا شارت الى ان الحرب اثرت على تعليم
اكثر من خمسه ملايين طفل اوكراني ولفت
سلان الوضع اسوء بالنسبه للاطفال في شرقي
اوكرانيا حيث تستعر الحرب منذ 8 سنوات وفي
الوقت نفسه فان اثنين من كل ثلاثه اطفال
لاجئين اوكرانيين في الخارج غير مسجلين
حاليا في نظام التعليم في البلد النظيف
وفي حينما كان قرابه مليونيه طفل يحصلون
على فرص التعلم عبر الانترنت فان انقطاع
الكهرباء بسبب الهجمات على البنيه التحتيه
يمثل تحديا للتعليم الافتراضي منظمه انقاذ
الطفوله نقلت عن وزاره التعليم والعلوم
الاوكرانيه ان اكثر من ثلاثه الاف منشاه
تعليميه بما في ذلك المدارس ورياض الاطفال
والجامعات قصفت منذ بدايه الحرب مع تدمير
اكثر من 400 من هذه المنشات بالكامل